vous savez une addiction au christine
dans une addiction ah oui alors mais
j'ai une addiction mais à quoi au
travail
ah bah c'est con pour l'année prochaine
je sors ce qu'ils estiment non mais en
plus je suis allé voir un psy quand
j'avais 20 ans parce que les si vous
pouviez leur sida jean michel maire
c'est lorsque j'ai pas de hobby j'aime
bien travailler sur plein de dossiers
différents des dossiers complexes je la
lis tout fadjiguila la nature la liste
est fascinant c'est une addiction c'est
quoi vit pas pour les lire quoi dormir
les lits d'ordre quoi mais lille béria
lille eli lilly
non pas du tout je vous donnais danis
manger oui gilles sioui et terre allait
devenir ce qu'ils mangent de la terre
mange des pierres ou déclenché des
cailloux c'est vrai regardez cet extrait
on voit une américaine td a qui ne peut
pas s'empêcher de manger des pierres
alors importante marée noire
[Applaudissements]
panic room à tsingoni mois le chocolate
chocolat noir blanc et olé vous mettez
un chocolat je suis là c'est normal
à commencer par l chocolate chip mais tu
crois quoi faire plus exotique
surtout qu'à un mix de quatre langues
dans sa phrase vous certaines addictions
moi pas vraiment non j'en suis je suis
pas la fin en fait j'ai des périodes où
et mais elles sont courts sert qu'à un
moment donné je vais focus sur du lait
concentré sucré
je vais manger que sa focus sur une
émission télé j'ai regardé que ça mais
je passe à autre chose j'ai pas une
addiction depuis toujours et la
melbourne cup et moi j'ai pas mal
d'habitude et ou à une addiction je
dirais que celle là si j'ai besoin
d'aller sur scène vraiment
vas-y un shoot compter sur scène et qui
a des gens devant toi qui t'y cas cette
paire de skis vont mourir ou pas etc
je crois qu'il ya un shoot il ya une
adrénaline et mais je pense que je n'ai
pas pendant longtemps ça me ça me manque
jean-michel aussi maintenant qu'il fait
du tati lassé d'être analysant les
séries c'est d'aller monter sur son dos
j'en suis pas eu bien sûr cet humour là
et non mais si quand même ses
contradictions ou la non j'ai eu j'ai
plus et je me suis soigné les chiffres
envoient les chiffres la roulette
ah oui non c'est un jeu d'échecs elle
chauffe musique c'était un signe que je
pouvais gagner sur tel chiffre et vous
si ruby je vais le case jouer le 15 à
roulettes j'ai perdu pas regardé en
train de faire pipi je voulais 24
qu'est-ce qu'il ya café vous quel est
votre addiction est ce que vous avez dit
jeanne oseille
ouais parce qu'on n'osait y avec sont
des marques ou des maladies que ça non
mais c'est très moche et toi je l'aurais
viré mais c'est déjà fait vous n'avez
pas répondu avec les addictions vrai
qu'elle est franchement à l'amitié
l'amitié ouest le score à la raison le
sport tu es est ce que je peux dire sans
flagornerie chef
oui vous savez pourquoi vous aime
l'argent que vous aimez données et pour
donner il faut en avoir et vous aimez
beaucoup donné c'est vrai est ce qu'il
aurait fait de la fièvre
[Rires]